it's been a pretty amazing surreal year
that I kind of keep pinching myself and
then really hoping I don't get the call
where someone goes King just kidding
it's a lot I mean I think I don't know
it makes you go it make it makes me go
back to my first first acting classes my
first classes with Groundlings and and I
think all those times that you just
think oh my God if I could just get a
commercial if I could get two
commercials a year I would I could go
down to two jobs and then you get a job
and it's like I think I still kind of
have that mentality of like I think I
have a job and I think I think you know
I won't have to go wait tables again and
I don't know and then you just see this
it's like I don't know that I even let
myself kind of imagine that farhad I
just always wanted to do work and I
wanted to like it and to have this meet
with something I love doing too is kind
of an annus I think to be kind of asked
to this into this party or brought to
this table and then to have all of the
women in that category be the women that
I find so amazing and Bionic and then to
have one of them be such a good friend
and you know the other women have gotten
to know and I I get really excited to
see other other women doing such
incredible work and I love the diversity
I love that the roles couldn't be they
couldn't be more different the women
couldn't be more different and that to
me just as a viewer and as an actress
it's really exciting to me you know I
talked about Groundlings before but I
have people that all I think everyone
was at my wedding so we've been really
really close friends for you know 13 14
years Octavia Spencer Jim rash and that
fax end that wrote The Descendants with
Alexander Payne Tate Taylor who you know
wrote and directed the help all of these
people an imam below like we've all
known each other for so long so we keep
all bizarrely showing up at these these
affairs together and I think we just I
think seeing them there it's like did we
break in now we're supposed to be here
okay
so it's May that it's like I think we're
all having the same kind of feeling of
like we're here let's it let's enjoy it
and I'm so proud of all of them that I
think it helps me kind of remember where
I am